[Musica]
porca [ __ ] che figata
tutti ragazzi venuti a questo video sono
fa dj ed oggi siamo il nuovo blog
diversissimo da tutto quello che avete
visto fino ad ora in questi giorni è
impazzata in rete questa mania di gelati
nizar e le bottiglie di coca cola sprite
fanta sembra una bottiglia ma in realtà
e gelatina e quanto può essere [ __ ] sta
cosa quanto da ieri sera ho iniziato a
queste cose sono tipo con la bava che mi
scende per terra infatti è tutto bagnato
e allo ragazzi in questo blog ho deciso
di fare una roba diversa da tutto il
resto cerco di farla io sta cosa qui non
so se riuscirò a farlo però ci voglio
veramente provare perché non ne ho
bisogno capite ne ho bisogno che i
ragazzi diamo inizio all'esperimento
crea la bottiglia dice latina con fari j
preghiamo dio di riuscirci sono andato a
prendere gli ingredienti ragazze non
abbiamo una coca cola un altra coca cola
perché ne farò due se riescono e faccio
due per ultimo ragazzi ci abbiamo il
conto per fare la gelatina ne ho presi 4
per essere sicuro di non sbagliare ai
ragazzi la prima cosa che devo fare
ecco strike la prima cosa che devo fare
è prendere la pentola devo metterci
dentro la coca cola questa qui sarà i
ragazzi io non so perché
non l'ho agitata perché ai ragazzi siamo
partiti di merda questa era prevedibile
bisogna ragazzi aprire questa cosa qui
come prima senza che esploda per l'amor
di dio si versa la coca cola tutta
quanta nella nel recipiente che non
userà mai più per cucinare in vita mia
perché mi farebbe troppo schifo
dopodiché ragazzi si inserisce la e
latina in fogli che non ho idea di
quanta ce ne vada però io inserisco a
caso e vediamo
sei stato di casa in teoria dovevano
andarmi la polverina non questo che
cazzo è sarò e forte sega prova a
metterla lo stesso prego iddio che
funzioni bava ragazzi ci provo lo stesso
e non so quanto possa funzionare però di
omuncoli a mostra cacata ovvio c'è però
il cuscino sul forno fantastico questa
cosa che stiamo facendo per esaltare la
casa questo il mio testamento mamma se
stai guardando questo video ti voglio
bene se si scaldasse mai questo schifo e
si sciogliesse alla gelatina
sarebbe fantastico un pochettino sta
reagendo ai ragazzi non si capisce che
cazzo succede però qualcosa sta
succedendo in tutti i fottuti video
fanno vedere che usano una polverina io
sto usando un coso di carta mi sembra di
fare tipo le streghe nei miei figli
cartoni animati che ci hanno il mestolo
che girano tipo vero iddio che funzioni
uguale perché se no non so proprio che
cazzo fare ok ora che abbiamo fatto sta
cosa si spegne per fresco nella gelatina
poi dovrà prendere la forma della
bottiglia
devo riferire tutta la coca cola dentro
la bottiglietta della coca cola vuota mi
servirebbe un imbuto ragazzo lo trovo un
imbuto nella pasta cotta in teoria devo
basta tagliare una bottiglia a metà
che bello c'è la stella se io metto
questo qua sopra così dovrei riuscire a
versare tutto quanto senza che faccia
casinò in teoria bisogna staccare
l'etichetta perché l'etichetta poi va
sulla sulla bottiglia finale una cosa
decente l'ho fatta oggi una sola prima
ancora di versare devo fare un'ultima
cosa devo tagliare la bottiglia in modo
tale che quando ci verso poi la gelatina
dentro io riesca a scartarla perché devo
poi scartare la bottiglia perfetto rega
ce l'ho fatta di home io non ci posso
credere mai devo scacciarla perché sennò
poi esce
la coca cola e grazie caso questo
momento o la bottiglietta finale c'è nel
senso qua ci va poi la gelatina che
diventa bottiglia se riesco io da
piccolo provava a fare tanti atac
tantissimi sapete quanti me ne sono
venuti ce l'abbiamo nel culo questo non
è un imbuto questa è un'arma ci siano
ragazzi al momento della verità non so
quanto possa riuscirci ma ci provo
sì grandissimo funziona
oddio no no no no no no no no facendo
cazzo cazzo cazzo cazzo stai vai vai vai
perfetto ok ci siamo salvati al pelo che
brucia del culo ce l'ho fatta a fare la
bottiglia ragazzi la cosa che mi rimane
da fare è prendere il tappo chiudere
questo posso fare questo incredibile
oh mio dio non ho fatto casino miracolo
questa brodaglia qui la prendo e la
metto ragazzi nel freezer questo tipo il
mio primo la infilo qua dentro ragazzi e
tra un'oretta circa la tirò fuori e
vediamo il risultato in gradito ai
ragazzi voi non avete idea del bordello
che ho fatto per fare una cazzo di coca
cola dello schifo ho fatto un bordello
di pil
ok ragazzi se uni nuovo qui sono passati
tipo 2 ore è arrivato il momento di
tirare fuori la bottiglia e non so se
sono riuscito non lo so io prego iddio
di sì vi assicuro che la cosa è
veramente straziante perché sennò non è
servito a un cazzo tutto sto casino
backup funziona se la piega non va giù è
veramente diventata gomma in realtà
ragazzi siccome è rimasto in freezer un
po d'acqua c'è davvero
ok ragazzi ce la sto facendo rete nel
casino o mio dio
oh mio dio non ci credo funziona
ragazzuoli porca eva che schifo calmo
stai calmo non so come descrivere questa
cosa ha una consistenza piuttosto strana
non so spiegarmelo allora è stranissima
è proprio la versione brutta della coca
cola di gomma però guardate che figo
e sembrato un pezzo di meteorite
stranissimo
non lo so che cazzo ne per completare
l'opera ragazzi manca solo una cosa
dobbiamo rimettere la cosa della coca
cola che non so come farà star su ok e
per concludere ragazzi il tappo che è
rimasto qui tutto il tempo perfetto euro
non è venuta malissimo come prima volta
pensavo peggio
se come quella che vedete nel video solo
che è un po più rigida però è così c'è
nel senso che balla brava che bella
quando si muove che figo va bene dai
questa cosa è troppo [ __ ] è la versione
un po cinese di quella che abbiamo visto
però è quella cioè nel senso ce l'ho
fatta ci sta che i pezzi e bellissimo
nella mia vita che scrivo non sono mai
riuscito a fare un cazzo di art attack
manco uno ma questo sì c'è più o meno da
una 10 io mi darei un sette e mezzo ci
sta mai da soli e direi che possono
chiudere qui il video è stata
un'esperienza traumatica ma allo stesso
tempo [ __ ] o distrutto mezza cucina però
avrà un altro discorso vero capito vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi spero che abbiate
imparato come fare una bottiglia di coca
cola gommosa e come rompere il cazzo ai
vostri genitori imbrattando di tutta la
cucina di di schifo ciò il muro
imbrattato di coca cola di pezzi di coca
cola santo iddio che un prologo episodi
ragazzi lasciate un bel mi piace per sto
video deve saltare il tasto mi piace
deve saltare fuori dopo deve esplodere
dai troppi laico cioè dio santo mi sono
imbrattato la cucina per questa cosa
quindi almeno questo schifo come se sì
vi è piaciuto documento è a me piace
anche a faccia di facebook e come lei
video trovate in description senza
vestiti scrivente non ci vediamo al
prossimo video bello ragazzi